サッブ パパッス アカラナン クサラッソ ウパサンパ ダ サチット パリヨ ダパナン エタング ブッダナ サーサナン
では よろしくお願いします
前回中野ゼロホールでなんか渋滞でちょっと十分遅くなりましたけど
も 今回は別な邪魔が入りまして
十分遅れるようになったんです
ということはセットで決まっているみたいです
えーでは よろしくお願いします
今日のテーマに早速入ります
ちょっとこちらでは綺麗に見えますけど
なんかスクリーンではちょっと色が濃くなってます
はい で 徳の悪い人 ない人というね
テーマで はい で 心を豊かにする採算運用
テーマっていうのはかなり
まあこれ我々はね 日常使っているフレーズを使って
その仏教的にそのポイントをどう見ればいいかということになるし
それよりも本当のところは
お釈迦様がおっしゃったこのすごい難しい理論をね
なんかどうでもいいテーマに入れておいて発表しているだけなんです
はい で 私たちは一応 まあ一般の社会ではね
まあなんか幸福な人々には徳があると言ったりするし
まあ空いてるという言葉も使ってますね
そこであの このフラワーアレンジメントっていうのは
まあ日本でよくあることですね
花の花を生けることね
で ヤタアピ ブッダ ラシマ カイラ マラ グネ バウ エヴァン ジャーテン マッチェナ カッタッバン クサラン バウ
ダンマパダの偈ですね
で これちょっと言葉知らなかった
花は花屋さんに買ったって結構束ごとに丸ごとたくさん買ってくるんですね
何のこともない 美しくもない
ただもうなかなか花っていう感じでね
それからあの この上手な人がね
その何の洒落もない花をとてもものの見事に美しく生けて見せるんですね
だから 生けた花をまた取り出しちゃって
もう束にしちゃったら何の美しさもなくなるんです
だから この花の生け方に何かすごい秘密があるんですね
同じ花ですけど あれは立て立て方によっての角度によって
我々にすごい美しい作品が現れてきて
心に喜びを与えてくれるんです
そのように我々も我々の人生をね
このフラワーアレンジメントのようにアレンジメントしなくちゃいけないんですね
だから 人間に生まれたら
何かで何かいいところはあるんですよ
いろんないいところがあるんです
これはものの見事にアレンジメントしてないんですね
正しく生けてないんですね
それだったら役に立たないんですよ
いくら例えば 10万円
20万円の花でも でっかいビニール袋に入れて持ってきたってもね
何の意味もないでしょ
何の意味もないんです
だから花瓶にしたっても
ものすごいでっかいものあったってもね
だから何？っていうことになるんですよ
しかし 花瓶に合わせてあの華道家が華道家って言うんですか
あの これ生けるんでしょうに
これでびっくり 魂が抜けるほど美しい作品
私も時々そういう花なんか見ていて
結構写真を撮っちゃうんですよ
私にとってものすごくつまらないものをね
ものの見事に組み立ててるんですね
それであの一つ一つすごいつまらなそうに見える葉っぱでも
生けたところで美しく
自分自分の美しさを演出するんですよ
それで我々理解するべきなのは
私たちも人間は不幸の連中じゃないんです
一応いろんなものを持って生まれているんです
それは正しく生かしてほしいんですね
持っているものはちゃんと
これはこちら これはこちら
これはこちらでちゃんと生けておけば
人生がものすごい美しい幸福な人生になるんですね
だから 何て言いますか
タイトルは徳があるないの話じゃないんです
大体人間って徳があるんです
この人とは この徳を全部ビニール袋に入れて紐でしまって置いておくんですね
あ 面倒くさい あ 面倒くさいとかね
だからこのお釈迦様おっしゃっているのは
このこれ花 インドではこの花瓶に花立てるよりも
みんな体に花輪を作って持つのは普通でしたからね
昔はね だからその冷房機能もあるしね
だからこの花を糸でつなげるんですよ
その時でも花の大きさ
色 いろいろ考えて 花輪として美しく花輪になるように作るんです
例えば王様とか家来とかでも
お妃たちとか並んでると
それぞれに合わせてちゃんと花輪作ってあげるんですよ
この花の職人たちが だから花輪を見ても
これは大臣だ これは何々さんだ
これは何々さんだとわかります
その例を見て お釈迦様が私たちにも善行為しなさいと
あの善行為すること たった簡単です
善行為することで 我々の徳が綺麗に整理整頓されて
美しくプロが生けた花の作品のように
人生が美しく輝くことになるんです
だからもうこれはこれで終わりましょうか
それだけです 善行為すればいいっていう話はブッダの言葉だから間違いなし
絶対間違いはないです
今日からまあくだくことではなくて
ちょっと良いことをしますよと
それに心変えただけで
その日から人生がもうどんどん徳のある人間として
幸福な人間として 恵まれた人間として
好いてる人間として成長していくんです
だから私たちはそうじゃなくて
何の善行為もしないし
何かやったらとんでもないことばっかりやってるし
それから好いてないわ
恵まれてないわ あれが悪いわ
これが悪いわ 上司が悪いわ
部下が悪いわとかね 奥さんが悪いが
旦那が悪い なんでもみんなにこれ言いながら
自分の生き地獄を餓鬼道を作って生きてるんです
これやめて善行為することになったら全て終わりますよ
花生ける人のように 自分の人生をアレンジするべきという意味ですね
はい あのプロデューサーオブライフ
プロデューサー プロデューサーというんですね
あれカタカナで書けないんだから
ちょっとローマ字にしちゃったんです
後で辞書を調べてカタカナの文字を見つけましたけどね
人生は自分が思う通りには進みません
これは皆様経験ありますね
私たち思う通りに人生進むわけ
ないんです 業というプロデューサー
いわゆる製作者がいます
だから私が生きてるんじゃなくて
この業がプロデュースしているんですね
製作しているんです この製作者が決まるように
だから大体映画にしたっても
プロデューサーっていうのは金出す人なんですね
だから金出す人はあまり金出してくれないといい映画は作れないでしょうね
時々ね まあもうもう １００億ドル ３００
億ドルまで使ってくだらない映画を撮るでしょうね
で 映画にストーリーも何もない
くだらないんだけど 派大な映画にはなります
それでみんな馬鹿みたく見て
お金また全部払ってあげるんですね
だからプロデューサーは損しませんね
プロデューサーの財産が増える一方で
それで映画っていうのはプロデューサーだけで成り立ちません
その人は金持ちで金出すだけでね
こちらに監督がいるんですね
映画監督 スクリプトを作って
そこは訂正して もうそれからそれぞれどんな風にそのその場面を撮るのかと決めて
ライトはどうするのか
お化粧どうするのか  プロデューサーが全部考えちゃうんですね
だからプロデューサーの中の頭の中にできた映画があるんですよ
まだ撮影始めてないんだけど
で そこは順番で撮って作品にするんですね
だからプロデューサーがなければ何もできないんだけど
監督の腕次第でしょ 作品は
それで我々の人生のプロデューサーは業です
それで我々生きることによって業が儲かっちゃうんです
業は減りません この人生生かすためには
業が必要なエネルギーを与えているんです
エネルギーは減ってるんです
生命エネルギーが 業 減ってるんだけど
我々生きることによって
もっとものすごい大量に業に力が入るんです
だから この映画世界でね
ドラマ世界であるこのプロデューサーと監督
見事に人生に合うんです
で プロデューサーという
例えば会社とかね 何かドラマを作るために金出しても
結局出した金よりはかなり利益を受けるんです
だから４億円払ったんだからって会社が倒産するんじゃなくて
かえって１００億円ぐらい儲かってるんです
私 我々の場合も 業が人生をプロデュースしていますけど
生きることによって業がものすごく強くなっちゃうんです
それで問題は 私たちの監督が盲目の感情なんです
だから感情が指令するように生きている
感情って分かってるでしょうね
怒りやら嫉妬やら憎しみやら落ち込みやら高慢
興奮 舞い上がり あれやこれやとかたくさんあります
感情は この感情には負けます
誰でも 怒りが出たら怒りに負ける
欲が出たら欲に負ける
だから欲の指令の通りに動く
だから俳優さんたちが
演出家がそうするしかないんです
監督が言う通りに動いて見せてみせる
ここでこけなさいと言ったら
物の見事にこけてみせる
ここで泣きなさいと言ったらちゃんと泣いてみせる
ここで怒りなさいと言ったら怒ってみせる
演出家が そこで私たちの監督はなんでしたっけ？感情
感情が欲を出したら 我々は欲に合わせて猿みたいに動いて動かして動いてみせる
怒り出してしまったら
怒りに合わせて体を動かして見せる
それで業が儲かっちゃうんです
それでポイントは 怒ってやることは悪でしょ？欲張ってやることは悪のエネルギーでしょ
業は悪のエネルギーでどんどん儲かっちゃうんです
業にとっては 善も悪もあんまり区別しません
ただ二種類だけで 善行はそこで善行の方に入れる
悪業は悪業の方に入れる
エネルギーですから うまく繋ぎますよ
だから業にとっては善であろうが悪であろうが
業を返してくださいだけなんです
思考と妄想が監督の助手です
そこで我々は思考するという何か変なことをやってますけど
怒りが出たら怒りに合わせて思考するんで
だから妄想なんです 欲が出たら
この欲をどうやって満たすのかと思考するんだから
そんな立派な思考じゃないんです
だから妄想と言った方がいいんです
時々思考しなきゃね 欲の欲を満たすことはできなくなりますよ
考えなくちゃ 怒りを満たすためにも考えなくちゃいけない時もありますからね
とにかく思考 妄想で妄想が助監督をやってるんです
で 監督は感情で感情が思考妄想でかなり強くなるんで
だから監督が結構もう自分には何といいますか
スタッフがいるんだから
このスタッフはすごく助けてくれるんです
そういうことで 人間の生き方はすべてダメになっているんです
徳のある人とは言えないんです
本当は いたって簡単なのに
恵まれた人で生きることはいたって簡単なのに
だから業が悪いんですか？業が悪くないんです
監督が悪いです プロデューサーは金出すだけだから
監督が映画を作らなくちゃあかんです
びっくりする作品もね
ボックスオフィスのね
何といいますか ヒットする
記録的にヒットする作品を作ることは
監督の仕事なんです スクリプト選ぶのは監督なんです
スクリーンプレイ書く人を探してね
これは作家たちですけど
監督が頼むんで あなたはこのこの本を持ってスクリーンプレイを書いてくださいと
ダイアログが気に入らなかったら
監督がもうこれちょっと変えてと言うんです
あのスクリーンプレイである場面がある
監督がえ この場面がいらんって言ったら
そこはカットしてつなげてくれるのは
それも監督が頼んでやってもらってるんです
だから映画の成功か失敗っていうのはスタッフのせいじゃないんです
スタッフが悪いんだったらクビにすればいいんです
監督が そういうわけで
我々の人生の場合は この悪いのは監督イコール感情なんです
だから仏教は この仕組みは苦しみの循環として見ているんです
だから我々は幸福になる生き方をしているんじゃなくて
苦から苦に 不幸から不幸になる
巡歩んでるんですね 循環なんですね
監督として理性と知恵を使うように推薦します
だからお釈迦様っていうのは
この監督を首にして 理性と知恵
監督にしてくださいと
それで終わり それでものの見事な人生を過ごしてくれます
そこで我々にとっては何の業がある？誰だって生きているんだから
業がなければ生きていられません
いわゆる財産というかね
資金はあるんです 問題は資金運用は感情
貪瞋痴がやっているんです
盲目です 感情は だから人生はダメになっちゃうんです
それで我々はちょっと苦労して理性と知恵に監督を頼むんです
それで相相接する幸福な人生に変わってしまいます
そうするとそれは幸福の道といいますし
幸福循環が生まれるんです
悪循環の代わりに はい
今日のテーマはそれで終了です
時間が余ってるんだから
別な話をします 人は多様です
バラエティヒューマンライフ
平等であるはずの人間は現実的にそうではありません
それについて経典から学びましょう
テーマに関係ないね テーマは終わった
私は苦しすぎて だから本当に何もポイントないテーマにしちゃったんだから
3 分でちょっと質問で答える感じで終わる終わるはずでしたけどね
長い講演にならない そういうことで
まあこの平等であるはずなんです
人間は でも現実的にはそうではありませんね
例えば生物学的に見れば
人間みんな同じ種類ですね
でも同じじゃないです
これ変です はい 次のテーマは人間の優劣はなぜ？これ今日使う経典はこのマッジメニカーヤウパリパンナーサカ
ヴィパッサナーワッガ 5番目の経典ですね
これ名前はチューラ・カンナ・ヴィパッサナー・スッタンというんです
で この経典で対話の経典で質問する人はスガトーデイプッタというかなりの大物の若い人なんですね
トーデイというのはものすごい有名なバラモンなんです
すごい知識人で超エリート
彼の息子なんですね 彼の出す質問は
この子 ボーゴートも ヘートゥーコーパッチャヨ
イエナマヌッサーナンイエーヴァサターンマヌッサブータナンディッサンティヒーナッパニタタ
人間であるにも関わらず
なぜ人間の間で優劣があるのでしょうかと
人間は平等じゃない ではトーデイウッドも
平等であるはずと思ってるんです
これおかしい 現実的にはおかしい
その理由をお釈迦様に聞くんです
それで質問の続きなんですね
この長い文章を読めるんですかね
私は早速読みますけどね
デ
ィッサンディボーゴートマヌッサアッパーユカーディッサンディディガーユカーディッサンティバッハバーダディッサンジアッパティアッパーバーダディッサンティドゥッパッナディッサンティワンナワントディッサン
ワンナワントおかしい
うん ディッサンティアッペサッカーディッサンティマエサッカーディッサンティアッパボーガディッサンティマハボーガディッサンティニーチェクリーナディッサン
ティウッチャークリーナディッサンティドゥッパニャディッサンティパンニャーワントーと
人間の差について語るんですね
この若者は 人間の間で一
短命の人 二 長寿の人 三
病弱な人 四 健康な人 五
見苦しい人 ある かっこ悪いんです
すごくかっこ悪い 六 美しい人
七 みじめな人 八 威力がある人
なんか現代日本語でなんか別な言葉使うんですね
なんで別な言葉使ってるの？例えばこのタレントさんなんか
あれやってると 選ぶ時はね
なんか誰だって同じ体形なんですけど
能力も まあ歌えるかで歌える
踊る まあそれなりの踊りです
みんなそれぞれ訓練して応募するんだからね
しかし パネルが別なもので選ぶんですね
あれはなんて言いますか
なんかなんかオーラみたいな人を惹かれる
もうちょっと何かあるんですね
例えば あまり訓練していない人であっても
完璧素人であっても あの力があったら
じゃあこの人に選びましょうと
それから訓練してあげればいいんじゃない？という感じで
それでちゃんと芸術学校を卒業しているのに
じゃああなた今度ですねというふうなことになっちゃうんです
それはこの威力というふうに私は訳しましたけどもね
九 貧困の人もいます 富豪もいますね
すごい金持ちの卑しいカーストの人
これは現代的にはあまりカースト制度日本でないんだから
まあこれは社会的な立場一だと考えた方がいいですね
社会的な地位 インドではカースト制度
十二 優れたカーストの人
十三 無知な人 十四 智者がいるのです
だから陶泥屋さんから見れば
彼が十四に人間を分けたんです
ご質問者が十四のカテゴリーにインドの当時の人々を分けて
なんだこれは？とお釈迦様に聞くんです
はい 次はお釈迦様の答えに行きます
業は生命のプロデューサーです
生命の優劣は業によるものです
というのは省略した意味なんです
業は生命の区別を行います
カンマンサッテービバジェティ
ヤリダンヒーナッパニータターヤーティ
業が生命の優劣という区別を行うのです
という意味なんですね
だからプロデューサーの金によって
プロデューサー出すお金によって作品...まあ言っていいかどうか分かりませんだけど
あの 東京のテレビ番組と地方のテレビ番組を比較してください
東京のテレビ番組は比較するとド派手で金は何の躊躇なく使っているんですね
地方の番組は本当になんか東京のテレビに慣れている人にとってはもう全く面白くないんですね
この大体タレントさんほとんど関西人でしょ
東京では本当にものの見事に番組をやっていて
で 東京で人程度なんで
人人程度で番組できて
すごい金かかってすごい番組を作るんだけど
関西テレビ見たら人じゃなくてもう人いるんですね
全部大物のタレントさんたちが
しかし 番組がすっごいダサいです
見ていられないです まあ関西の方々はそれに笑うかもしれませんだけど
うーん 私は笑えない番組として見ているんですね
いかに気持ち悪くなってなるのかというのは
同じタレントさんマさんとかもっと長い時間いるんですよ
だからそこはどこ あの人たちに能力ないわけじゃないんです
そちらのプロデューサーの問題なんですよ
そこでもっともっと田舎に行ったら
もうほとんどもうプロデューサーがなくて
二人だけでなんとかなんとか
時々マーケットのいろんなものを見せたりもしますけど
なんだこれはと で  NHKでもあるでしょ？いろんな地方に行って
いろんな その時かなり派手
地方のことを紹介するとき
なぜかというと  NHK がもうものすごい金出しちゃうんですね
だからプロデューサーがどれぐらい金を出すのかということによって
いくら優秀な監督であっても
作品にはちょっとレベルが成り立つのです
それでお釈迦様がおっしゃっているのは
この人間のこのでしたっけ？種類の差が業の問題ですと
プロデューサーの問題です
いわゆる資金の問題なんです
資金足らなく足りるかどちらか
それから詳しく説明していきます
1 短命 短命っていうのはこの殺生の業なんです
命に対して憐れみがなく
残酷で 血にまみれた手を持ち
人は殺生します その業によって死後地獄に不幸に陥ります
もしも人間で生まれたならば
短命になります 長生きできません
歳で死ぬかも 形で死ぬかも
歳で死ぬかも 歳で死ぬかも
結構いるんですよ そういう人々は
時々かなり活発で有名で
ものすごいバリバリ仕事をしている人々もぷっと早く死んでしまうということもあります
そこで有名人の中でね
そういう仕事も辞めて
もうテレビに出ることも
映画に出ることもなく
ボロボロ年で歳 歳 歳までいる人々もいる
タレントさんの中でもう歳で逝っちゃったという人もいる
だから何か業に欠けているんですね
だから短命になるのは殺生という業なんです
だから殺生することも業なんです
殺生するたびに業が強くなるんです
しかし 殺生っていうのは破壊エネルギーだから
その資金でできるのは破壊することだけ
例えば爆弾を作るために金かかるでしょ？じゃあ爆弾で何ができますか？真っ暗にして寝ること
他何もできません 爆弾でできることは破壊することだけです
だから殺生して殺生して原子爆弾みたいな破壊力持っちゃうと
まあ知ったことじゃないんです
今もこの世の中でね もう中東の国々にシリア
いろんなところであるでしょ
トルコとか それからエジプトとエジプトじゃなくて
もうイラクとかね それからインドの方になってくると
もうパキスタンにもあるし
アフガニスタンとかね
毎日破壊 破壊 破壊 破壊
人は死ぬ死ぬきりがなく死ぬ
この死ぬ運命の人間じゃないんだよ
すごい体力がある 若いし
年寄りを選んでテロをやっているわけじゃないんです
だから業っていうのはエネルギーですから
このこれはもうエネルギーはもう結果出して消えるものででなきゃ消えないんです
だから私が死んだら業も全て一緒に死ぬわけじゃない
私は死にますけど 業ってエネルギーですから
それは死なない それプロデューサーだから
その業が新しい命をプロデュースするんです
それが我々はこの輪廻転生
生まれ変わり 生まれ変わるわけないでしょ
これ科学的なおかしいくだらんこと言ってますけど
そういう話じゃないです
業が一つの生命をプロデュースする
それは壊れる 壊れたら
その業がまた新しい生命をプロデュースする
それも壊れる またその業がまた新しい生命をプロデュースする
それが輪廻転生というんです
同じ業がプロデュースするんだから
だから業が減らないって言ったら減らないんです
増えることはいくらでもあります
だから私の人生が 私は成功しようが失敗しようが
そちらのエネルギーが業に入ってくるんです
プロデューサーはもうかる
苦労はしない 苦労するのは監督とこの演出する私たちなんです
はい それは 第1は殺生なんですね
これパーリ語ってかなり恐ろしくお釈迦様に説かれてますけどね
もう何のルッドあだよ
パンのルッタっていうのは
まあ残酷かな なんのみじんも可哀想っていう気持ちがなく
生命なら殺すべきやと IS
の人々を見てと同じ感じで
自分たちの思考は持たない人はみんな殺すべきです
だから自分の同じ宗教の人々を殺しているんです
だから極まりのない残酷でしょう
言い訳成り立たない イスラム国家を作らなくちゃあかんやと言ったら
だから人を殺すのは何なのかと
人々のために国を作るでしょう
だからあなた方をまず殺さなくちゃいけないんだと
だからまるっきりもう残酷
獣が持っている道徳さえもないんです
そんなことをやっちゃうと
その本人たちもすぐ短命でしょうに
アメリカやらロシアやらいろんな国々がもうあのなんとか無人飛行機まで使ったりして狙って狙って殺す
だから まあそういう殺生に行っちゃうと
自分の命も短くはなります
長寿になること そちらの反対ですね
不殺生の業 一切の生命に対して慈しみを抱き
殺生をしない人 死後天国に生まれる
人間として生まれた場合は長寿になります
生命を守ってあげる パーナティパタンパハヤパーナティパタパティヴェラトホーティニヒタダンドーニヒタサットニヒタダンドー武器持たない
ニヒタサットニヒタダンダっていうのは棒を持たない
人を殴る 生命を殴るために何を持たない？ニヒタサット
刃物あれやこれやとか持たない
アメリカ人みたいに誰のポケットにピストルあるとかないんです
棒といったら まあ足が弱いんだったら杖ぐらいは持つかもしれませんだけど
武器たるものは何を持たない
それだけで一切武器を捨てると思ったら
ものすごい人生は安心なんですよ
それで必ず死後天国に生まれる
それで天国の期限が終わったら
もし人間になるかも 人間になったらすごい長寿
それから病弱 健康 病弱っていうのは
この生命をいじめる害を与える後
殺すってことじゃなくていじめる
人は手 石 棒 刃物などで生命に害を与えることをします
この性格の人は死後地獄に不幸に陥ります
もしも人間として生まれることがあっても
病弱になります イダマーナはエーカッチョイッティア
プルソーはサッターナン
ビヘータカジャーティコホーティ
生命に迷惑をかける パーニナーヴァレッドナーヴァダンデーナヴァサッテーナヴァ
ソーテーナカンメーナエワンサマッテーナエワンサマディニ
そこでこのとにかく人に迷惑をかける
人だけじゃなくて 他の生命にも迷惑をかける
石を持って投げるわ 棒を持って殴るわ
いろんな道具を使って生命をいじめるわ
だから人間が人間をいじめるだけじゃないんですよ
どんな生命 そこであの後からもこのポイントを言いますけど
最初から言った方がいいと思いますけど
これはこの一回やったことではないんで
この場合は このその性格として
その生き方 するんです
いわゆる性格になっているんです
健康っていうのは 生命に優しい人
害を与えない人 それであるせま誰にも動物にも迷惑をかけない
いじめない 痛めつけない
どうか元気で生きていてくださいという気持ちで生活している
仲間同士でもいじめはしません
蹴ったりはしません 人の足を引っ張ることはしません
そういう性格だったら
自分がすごい健康な人間になる
これ人間になったら健康
そんなすごい善行でしょ
だからすぐ天国に行くんです
例えば 自分のポリシーは生命はいじめません
生命には迷惑をかけませんというポリシーで生きているならば
人間の社会でいろんな方法でいじめができますよ
いろんな方法で 人をいじめるといったら
もういろんな方法があります
はい そこで いかなる場合でも
人が嫌な気持ちになること
人の幸せを壊れること
人の幸せな家族がバラバラになること
会社のね 運営に邪魔になること
そういうのは全くしない
これは迷惑 人様に迷惑ということで
私はいかなる場合でもやりませんと自分の人格を作るんです
これだったらもう直行で天国に生まれるし
人間に戻ってきてもものすごい健康体
はい 美しく生まれる秘訣
これだけでも覚えておきましょうか
はい まず五番目 見苦しい人
それ怒るっぽい 恨みを持つという業なんです
我々の性格が怒りっぽくて
なんかちょっとやったらすごい恨みを持つならば
もうすごい醜い体で生まれるんです
プロポーションが最低で悪くて
わずかなことであっても激怒する
自分の怒りを他人にぶつける
このような性格の人は
人間として生まれる場合は見苦しい体を持つんです
あ 聞きなさいと言われる体になるのです
近寄れないと イダマーナエカッチョイッティーワプリソワ
若者よ ここで女か男がコーデの方で奪い合わせ
バウロ 怒りっぽくて恨みを持つだとしましょう
アッパンピフットーサマーナ
ほんのわずかなことを言ってもアビサッジャで激怒する
クッパティ怒る ビャーパッジャティ
恨みを持つ パティッターイティコーパンチャドーサンタアッパッチャンチャ
怒り 嫌な気持ちでずっとずけた状態でいる
もうどうにもならなくなっちゃう
ソーテーラカッメーネエーワンサマッテーナエーワンサマディンネーナカーヤサベーダンパランマラナアパーヤンドゥッカティンビニパタンニレヤンウパッジャティ
この人はその性格で その生き方で
スーッと生きてるならば
自分を改良する必...気持ちはない
このままでやりますと
だいたい私たちは皆同じですよ
自分の性格は変えたくはない
変えたくはないでしょう
何か人に放っておけと言うんでしょ
それは私の性格だから
だからこういう悪い性格になってくると
同じ態度で変える気持ちはないんですね
それだったら死後地獄に行きますよと
そこで美しい人はもうわかりますね
怒らない 恨みを持たない
豪快にたくさんのことを言われても怒らない
恨みを持たない 嫌な気持ちにならない
性格が 美しい体で生まれるごです
すごい このみんなに好かれる大人気者になる
すっごい美しい体なんです
そういう方々は赤ちゃんで美しい
子供で美しい 若者で美しい
成人になっても美しい
中年でも美しい 老年ででも美しいのです
皆様の社会でもちょこちょこと調べたらそういう人間いるでしょう
おばあちゃん おじいちゃんになってもえらい格好よくて
そこでこの私はこの言葉入れよう入れようと入れてなかったんだけど
アッコードのほうでアヌパアヌパヤスバフロー
怒り 怒らない 恨みを持たない
バフミ仏様のたくさん言われても
ナービスアンジャティ気にもしない
まあ別にという感じで
ね クッパで怒りません
ね ビャーパジュティ 恨みを持たない
ね パティッターヤティ
怒りの方がこの人わからないんですね
いつでも微笑んでいる
それで それだけのことで怒らないだけのことで
死後天国に生まれるんです
何があっても微笑み微笑んでいる
いましょう それはポリシーとして決めなくちゃいけないんです
一回二回だけでは意味がない
人生そのものを微笑みというした方が死後心配する必要はないんです
そこで人間に生まれたらすごい美しい体
はい 次に行きます  7番目
惨めな人 これは嫉妬の部
惨めな人っていう言葉がいいかどうかよくわかりませんだけど
パーリ語はアッペイサッカなんですね
他人の幸福 財産 名誉などに対して嫌な気持ちになって嫉妬を抱く性格の人は
死後地獄に陥る 人間に生まれることがあっても惨めな生き方になる
何の力もない 何の威力もない
あんたって人間ですか？と聞きたいぐらい
もうもう存在感は全くない
グループを組んで旅に出たっても
その人と忘れちゃいます
で ちょっと健康でバスに乗ったら
じゃあみんないる？はい
いますいます  OK はい
では出発です あの人はまだ乗ってないと
そういう存在感がない人がいるんですよ
その中でもどうしてもすごい存在感があって
ものすごいいるから人もいる
だからなんで存在感がない
私はこの旅行やってる人々はそれをわかっているみたいですね
みんないるんですかと聞かないんです
ずっと首を数えるんです
数えて数字があって  OK
行きましょうと言うんです
その方がやっぱり旅行会社としては安心です
このバスには 14人乗っているんだと
それでもう自由フリー見学してから
この時間でバスに乗ってくださいと
乗ったら まあみんな乗りまったという話も聞かないで
じっと数えてみて あと二人足らないと言うんですね
それで本人がリスト持ってますから
何さん何さん足らないとかね
言ったりするし それで数字が合ったら
じゃあ出発ということになるんです
これ 存在感でチェックしちゃうと大変なことになるんです
それは嫉妬する業なんですね
嫉妬とは このパララバサッカーガルーカーワンダナガルーカーマナナワンダナプージャセナプージャセプージャプージャプージャナースプージャナース
人々が褒められると 人々が結構収入が得られると
どんどん儲かって豊かになっていくと
もう我慢できない それを嫉妬する
で 嫉妬するとものすごく心が暗くなるんです
そのエネルギーが業に入るんです
感情で生きているんだから
それでこの命が潰れたら死ぬでしょ
業にたくさんのエネルギーが溜まったんだから
その業で次の生命をプロデュースするんです
それは地獄でプロデュースするんです
それで その業が地獄でプロデュースしないで
人間として新しい生命プロデュースしたら
それが何の存在感もないんですね
で  8番目の人間っていうのは威力がある人
マヘーサンカラ グレートピーポーっていうかね
パワフルグレートピーポー
グレートという言葉を使いますね
グレートですかね 他人の富
名誉などに嫉妬の気持ちを起こらない性格の人
人間に生まれるときは威力のある人になります
他人が成功するとよかったねとかね
本当に楽しくなっちゃうんです
二人受験しても自分が落第して友達が合格したらよかったよかった思うでしょ
素直に楽しむんです 人の幸福を
その性格だったら死後必ず天国に行く
人間になってもかなりパワフルな魅力のある人間になるんです
どこへ行ってもなんかみんなすぐあ
何々さんが来たとかね
だからこのマヘーサッカっていうのは
このこちらに入った途端
なんかこの場所 この場所がなんかその人の力でなんかずっと行き渡ってしまうんですね
存在感は否定できない
まあ例えば日本でね たくさんとく住んでいる例といえば
例えばもう皇室の方々とかね
何か公の行事があって
その誰かが来ると みんなそちらにピンポイントして活動するんです
外からも もうその場所に入らない人も
外にいる人も みんな皇室の方々とお天のお姿をお子様誰かが
例えば車で行く場合でも
たくさん車並んでいくでしょ
誰も見ない人はね 結構派手に車
警察のいろんなオートバイやら色々綺麗に行くんだけど
それじゃなくて真ん中に車の方を見て
窓の中からなんとか見えようかなと
見えるかなと そこまでそちらに集中するんです
別に普通の人間と同じなんですけど
でもなんであそこまであれ？威力なんですね
マヘーサッカ だからそういう方々を見ると
過去の業の気配見えるでしょ
人の幸福を素直に喜んじゃうの
よかったねとかね だからちらちらと過去の業の気配も見えてきます
はい 次は貧困と富 はい
貧困の業は物惜しみの業
ちょっと間違ってますが
重要は忘れてください
シャモン これはインドの当時の時代に合わせて書いてますからね
シャモン バラモンたちに
いわゆる出家修行者ですね
食べるもの 飲み物 着るもの
住むところ 薬などのその他のその他を施しをしない性格の人
貧困に生まれる業をしているんです
いるんです あんな連中は社会迷惑じゃとかね
１円もあげるなよと そうやって怒る人々もいる
どうせあの正しい出家ではなくてね
金目当てに出家する修行者になる人もいますよ
例えば乞食に何か上げてあげるのは構いませんだけど
乞食業やっている人々いるんです
スリランカではもうかなりそれは厳しく取り調べてやめさせてますけど
最近さらにこのこれ断固禁止しなくちゃいけないんだと
だからお金がない人は何かちょっとちょうだいというのは構いません
だからあげる人も気持ちいいんです
そうじゃなくて この何といいますかね
書籍作って 乞食はこういう風にやるもんだよとかね
服はこういう風に着るんだよとかね
こういう風にお願いするんだよ
それから子供を借りて貸してあげるんです
1日いくらっていうことで
そこで道路であの悪環境で
もう車渋滞で迷惑かけて
赤信号で車止まったらサッと来て
もうドアにポンポン叩いて
で 子供を抱っこして 私はあげたくはないんです
それ黙ってるんで 運転する子はもうさっさとお金あげちゃうんで
いつもやってることにやめなさいと言えないだからね
私はその貧しい人々に結構あげますよ
もうハチャメチャあげるんだけど
ああいうことには反対なんですね
子供って言ったって もう命でしょうに
人間でしょ 健康なところでいい食べ物を食べさせて育てなくちゃいけないんでしょうに
誰でもいるんだから そういう実の親のいない子供だったらもらいましょうと
いくらでもいるんですよ
...だからこんなのはもうもう悪魔をいいところなんですね
だからこの だからインドっていうのはもう宗教家っていうのはいるわ
いるわ いるわ 人間 インドだったらもう何百
何千人もサードたちが
みんなインチキですよ
ものすごい横蛮単義で金儲かってる
世界からも金儲かっちゃう
なんか変な服を着たら素晴らしい精神的にできてる人で
外国人ももう勘違いするんだから
何もない まあとにかくそれを置いといて
修行者に困っている人に
何かやっぱりあげなくちゃいけないんですよ
助けてあげなくちゃいけないんですね
そういうことは いわゆる施しすることに反対ということは
すごい物惜しみですね
だから物惜しみでの性格はもったいない
例えば 時々子供たちも金募金する活動をやっているでしょ
一年何回とかね その時でも
まあもし元気な明るい子供たちだったら
さっと並んでおじさんたちを囲まっちゃうんですね
何だら何だらで募金してくださいと
子供たちも喜んでやってます
与えられた仕事だからね
別に何も詐欺も何もないし
それで逃げられなくて
例えば百年空きがなくなっちゃったとかね
あのガキたちのせいでとかね
そういう物惜しみの性格ですよ
そういう人々は死後地獄に落ちる
でなきゃ人間に生まれても貧困
金がない この貧困ってすごい面白いんですよ
で ホームレスみたいになっちゃって金がない人もいるんだけど
日本ではもう本当は貧困っていうのはありえない国なんですね
なぜならば 日本人の性格を見ると
何かしら何かあげる習慣なんですね
いつでも 例えば政治家は賄賂を取ったり
あれやこれや このアメリカとかの考えは
日本では中元とかね いろいろ習慣がありますからね
だから政治家に中元とお正月をあげるもの
何て言いますかね  お歳暮か
歳暮とかね やっぱり文化だから結構なものをあげますよ
もう金束とかね それは政治的に見れば賄賂を取ったことになっちゃうし
でもこれ法律は西洋的な法律だからね
でも日本人っていうのはやっぱり何かあげたいというね
人の家に行く場合は必ず何か持っていくんですね
つまらないものを  （笑）だからあの
あけることを民族的に
文化的にもうなりきっているんです
だから貧困にならないんです
なのにいるでしょ 数は少ないんだけど
そういう人があと可哀想でたまらない
だってどう見たってもこの人はちょびっと仕事をすれば金が入るのにとかね
いい仕事をやっていたのになんで辞めたんですか？とかね
言いたくなるんですよ
そこでほんとしてなんですかね
貧乏の家で生まれた？小さい時から食べるものもなかった
そうではないでしょ 普通にバリバリ仕事をして金回りも良くて
それで滑っちゃって だから業ですから滑りますよ
それですごい悲しい生き方をするんです
ガードルのせいだとか
あれ考えてください もう六時半になってくると
ああいう人々はどこか寝床を作って寝ているんです
六時半から寝るということは
考えられない 私は これで超気持ち悪くないのかと
それで寝られないんだから
ガラスカップの酒あり
四つ五つぐらいガブガブと飲んで
だから最悪状態でしょ
なんでそうなったのかというと
その人々の監督 感情ですからね
監督が下手な作品を作っちゃって滑ったんです
なんでそうなったのか
それも過去の業 ものしめの業で貧困になるんです
そこで十番目は施しの業
施しを好む人は死後天国に生まれます
人間として生まれる時は富豪になります
いるでしょうね 嫌でも金が入る人々は
何やろうとすぐもう儲かっちゃうんです
本人が別に儲かるつもりもまるっきりない
ただもうなんか面白くね？なんかやっちゃいましょうという
ただ面白半分でやってるんだけど
ヒットする それで何もやらないでつまらないな
なんか面白いことないのかと思って考えて
またやったらまたヒットしちゃう
だからもう金が入りすぎちゃって嫌でたまらない人々が世の中にいるんですよ
それが過去に 何と言いますか
布施を 施しを好んだ人々なんです
あるものは分けてみんなで使いましょうよとかね
このビル・ゲイツさんもね
今いろんな福祉活動 いろんなものに手を出してるんですよ
面白いことは ものすごい金使っていろんな資金とか作ってますけど
本人の財産が減らないんです
本人が組織がずっと続けるように考えて何か作るんですね
そうすると自分が一部お金に行ったんだけど
それからお金に行かない
行かないんです あのお金でずっと続ける
だから金が入る業だからもう仕方がないんです
だから過去生でもね いろいろ施しを好んだ人でしょう
だからそこですごい金持ちだって言って威張ることもないし
もうすごい金持ちだからなかなか一般人に会えないかもしれませんだけど
どこへ行ったってみんなと仲良くニコニコと笑って
まあ親しみも生まれてくる
だから その人の名前を出していいかどうか分かりませんだけど
まあそういう人間が日本の社会でも聞くらでも調べればいる
でお釈迦様はあえて言っているのは
この修行者っていうのは
お釈迦様はもうやっぱり修行者の中でもちゃんと心清らかにしましょうよとかいう真面目な人々もいます
宗教だからおかしいんだけど
でもお釈迦様はその人の生き方はそんなにおかしくはない
解脱なんか値がないんだけど
でも仕方がない 生き方は正しいんだから
だからそういう人々を助けてあげた方が人間の社会にすごい貢献します
特にこの乞食にお金をあげていいかどうかっていうことで
乞食がこれいい商売やと思っちゃうとね
これ社会迷惑なんですよ
乞食と日本の新興宗教とかはね
これはいい商売やと これで開祖様たちが現れる
現れる まあ最終解脱たちは次から次に現れるは
ブッダが生まれ変われるは
ありともしないものが現れる
涅槃に入ったブッダが生まれ変わると
あの馬鹿の知識の量わかる
病気だから仕方がないんだけど
だからこのそういうものは社会にとっては迷惑なんですけど
正しく修行する人々に善悪を教えてくれる
人がいればね 例えば学校に行って
子供たちに怒りを収める方法やら
仲良くする方法やら もうどうやって勉強
そういう道徳的なことを教える組織があれば
どれぐらい社会役に立ちますかと
例えば これは私の架空的な話で
日本ではそういう修行をする組織がいるとしましょう
で 金もうかる目的は一切なしやと
しかし 日本社会は必要なものは用意してあげる
食べるものやら建物やら住むところやら
その人々はただで無料で
至る所に行って人々の面倒を見ると
例えば学校を登校拒否する子供たちを連れてきて
ご飯を作ってあげて いろいろ修行させて
しっかりした性格の人間として育てる
それには子供たちから
親からこれぐらい金くれはなし
そうするとこの組織は社会が助けてあげる
そういうふうなことがあったら
いかにこの国が助かるんですかね
突然犯罪することなくなっちゃうでしょ
子供たちとか 登校拒否したり
親と喧嘩して親ぶん殴ったりとかね
親に管理できない子供とか現れますからね
それでこの組織がノコノコと行って
うちに来いと言ったら
そちらももうもう金取ってはわけ邪魔なくいいんだから
すごい仲良く生活直るようにというふうに
だからこの まあこれは日本で無理ですけど
で 日本にはそういう組織が必要なんですよ
結局は だからそれは修行者の組織というならば
その組織に必要な食べるもの
住むところとかね そんな大した金額かからないでしょう
それぐらいのことをあげるのは社会
社会のためにやる素晴らしい行為なんです
だから 修行者に何かをすることで
その人はその社会全体に貢献しているんです
だから お金無駄に行ったわけじゃないんです
千円で弁当を買って食べるよりは
千円をそういう正しいところに寄付したら
これは百万円の価値があるんです
わからない その人々はどれぐらい人類にを人類を助けているかわからないんだから
ですから この布施ということは社会的に見てもすごい必要なことで
仏教的に見るのはまた別
心理学的にはね 心理学的に見ると
自我でこれも私のもの
これも私のもの あれも私のもの
そうでないものは あれも私のものにしたい
これも私のものにしたいという
もう世界の宇宙の生命のものは全部自分の方向に引っ張ろうとする
そうすると 世界全体的にここから逃げようとすごいエネルギーを作るんです
それが貧困になるんです
一人の人間に社会のものすべて引っ張ろうということは不可能だから
それで社会 巨大な社会がこの人から逃げるんです
だから引っ張るんです
だから自分には金が入らない状態になってしまう
金っていうのは現代的な用語で
生きるために必要な財産は入らない
たとえやっと人から家もらっても
家がすぐ地震で潰れてタコ足になっちゃうことになる
はい 次 社会的地位十一番卑しいカーストの人
それは業はちょっとフォーマットを壊れちゃったんです
何業かというと この自我を張る業
いわゆる傲慢 傲慢という業
傲慢でいることは恐ろしい業なんですよ
だって傲慢って性格でしょ
殺生っていうのは性格でなくても
たまたま殺したっていうこともあり得るでしょ
例えば一年に一回ぐらい釣りに行くとか
あり得る しかし この傲慢の場合は
それ性格なんです はい
頑固 傲慢 なんか文章ちょっとおかしいところありますね
という業で 尊敬するべき人を尊敬しない
礼をするべき人に礼をしない
敬意をするべき人に敬意をしない
気にもしない 挨拶もなし
パーリ語で言えば 男か女か
すごい硬くて頑固で傲慢
頭を下げて こうやって礼をするべきところには礼をしない
お世話してもういろいろお世話するべきでは
それはやらない 椅子をあげるべき人にはどうぞというふうに椅子をあげない
アーサナーラッサナーアーサナンデーティ
マッガーラハッサナマッガンデーティ
道を開けてあげない あげ
あげ 道を開けてあげなくとは
人に道を開けてあげない
サッカータッバンナサッカロティ
尊敬する人を尊敬しない
次の同義語でパーリ語で
この尊敬っていうのはサッカロティガルカロティマーネーティプージェーティという四種類なんですね
ちょっと私は日本語の単語を知らないんだからね
頭下げる 手を合わせるとかね
心ですごく大事な人だと思うこととか
いくつあります 世の中でそういう人間いるんです
私より何とか目上の人は必ずいるんですね
だから 私より目上の人々に対して
このどんな角度で目上かというのは
その場その場変わりますからね
いろんな立場で見ると
この人は目上 例えば年だけ計算すると年の上の人は目上ですね
知識から計算してみると
学生さんに対しては先生が目上の存在なんですね
子供にとって親はもう断然的に目上なんです
スポーツ世界では プロのスポーツ選手が
あるいはコーチが普通の人々に対しては目上なんです
だから いろんな社会で
いろんなところで いろんな立場で目上っていうことになり立つんです
国会議員さんはその地方の一般人よりは目上なんです
だから それはどんなところで目上かと見て
それにふさわしい礼儀作法を使わなくちゃあかんのです
だから これをわかりやすく言えば
この礼儀作法なんです
礼儀作法がない人っていうのは
すごい頑固で傲慢なんですね
逆に見ればすごい野蛮人なんですね
本人が傲慢で俺が偉いと思ってるんだけど
野蛮人なんですね それで野蛮人な人が地獄に行くんです
礼儀作法なかったら これ正確です
その場でその場で 何かの形で目上の人っていうのは現れます
まあ例えばどこかで空港でもよろしいし
デパートでもよろしい
これなんとかインフォメーションデスクがあるんですね
案内するところ まあ若い女の子二人ぐらい並んでね
何もわからなくてね アホでいるんだけど
でも私が何かにどこかに一回デパートで聞きあったんだけど
何か品物を買いたくて
で  12階も歩き回ったって迷子になるだけだから
どこにあるかわからないんですよ
そこでインフォメーションのところに行って
そうするとすごい行儀正しく礼儀正しく
実はね 私はこういう品物を買いたくて探してますけど
どこにあるんですか？って言ったら
もうわからなくて さっさとあれ見て
ああ こちらにありますよでって
こういう風にすごい丁寧に教えてくれる
だから私は行儀作法なく聞いちゃうと
これ教えてくれるかもしれません
向こうは行儀作法があるんだからね
でも自分の態度は何なのかと
自分が悪業したんです
だから私は 80歳で年上で
こんな若者 それその瞬間で向こうは怒られちゃうんです
だから このその場その場で瞬間で目上目そうでないということになっちゃいますよ
そこをよく気をつけて生活していなくちゃあかんですね
いつでも年下はいつでも目上じゃない
けなすこと それはできませんよ
そういうことで これすごい正確なんです
礼儀正しい それで礼儀ない人はいくら胸張っても野蛮人で
野蛮人が人間に生まれ変わっちゃうと
このものすごい低いカースト
人に生まれるんです だから
それでちょびっとインドのことを考え出した方がいい
インドではもう今はなかなかほとんど派手にないんだけど
もうカースト低いカーストの人々にはもう学校に行ったら追い出すわ
井戸から水を汲むことは禁止するわ
大変なんです 家に何か用事があって来ても
家の中には入れてあげないわ
そこで現代社会ではカースト制でなくても業があるんだから
社会的な地位が全くない
みんなに取り扱いされるような状態で
言いたい放題ことで全然遠慮もしない
言っちゃう言っちゃうし
敬語も使わないし なんであなたはという感じで
だから社会的な地位がなくなっちゃうんです
そこで優れたカーストの人っていうのは
柔和で傲慢で高慢ではない性格
柔軟な性格で高慢ではない人は
人間として生まれる場合は高貴な生まれになります
あとで今 12番 あと 2つしかないんですね
無知と知者の区別  13 無知な人
真理 道徳を学ばない 学ばない
マル入れなくちゃ学ばないって業なんですね
なんかおかしい で 修行者
心を清らかにしている人々を尋ねて
善は何？悪は何？何をしてはならない
何をするべきですか？死後幸福になるためにどうすればよいなどを
伺わない 学ばない人は人間として生まれる場合は武者になります
これ地獄に行く道なんですね
善はなんですか？悪ってなんですか？私はどんな生き方をすればよろしいですか？私はどういうことをやってはいけないでしょうか？とかね
これ学ばない  k 正位たっばんきんね
正位たっばん 誰と付き合うばよろしいかとかね
誰と付き合うのはやめるべきかとかね
きんめからにやん ディーガラったん
会いたい使いドゥッカいほうて
私はどうすればとことん不幸になるんでしょうかと
逆に私はどうすれば長きにわたって幸福になるのかどうかね
そこを学んでください
学ばない人は無知になる
智者っていうのは真理
道徳を学ぶという業なんです
俗世間的だけど 知識に知識はこの世に限ります
これを覚えてください
皆様が学校に行って学ぶことを
大学に行って学ぶことは俗世間の知識ですよ
それは死んじゃったら終わりです
これは人間の肉体を維持するための話だけなんです
生命はそんな単純なものじゃないね
業がいて 一つの生命をプロデュースしているだけで
この生命は壊れる するとその業が別な生命を作る
そこでそちらの感情という監督がいて
またひどいことをやる
ですから 人間という生命体を作ったら
その生命を維持するために必要な学校に行って学んだりするんだけど
それは長きにわたって役に立ちません
長きにわたって役に立つのは
この業が悪業ではなく
善業になる方法なんです
だから人間なら道徳は学ぶべきです
生き方は学ぶべきです
他何を学んだっても 善行には関係ないんです
肉体を維持するためだけです
肉体は潰れます そういうことで
超エリートであっても
人間の体ある時だけです
そこが壊れたら 業が 例えば畜生の生命プロデュースしたらどうします？あの知識何も役に立たない
地獄に落ちたら何の役に立つ？しかし
道徳を学んだら 生き方を学んだら
善悪を学んだら それが業に直接影響を与えるんです
業が善業になるんです
良い業になるんです そうすると
次に業がいい生命をプロデュースするんです
だからお釈迦様は直接天国に行く
天国に行くと言っているんです
あるいは直接地獄に落ちると
業がやってるんです はい
それで経典の結論 カマッサカーマノサッタカマダヤーダカッマユニカッマバンドカッマパティサラナーヤカッマンサッティウバリヤイダンヒーナッパニッターヤ
生命の生き方によって
性格によって差が生じるのです
生命の差を業が決める
生命は業を相続する 生命業に頼って生まれる
業を遺伝する 遺伝子じゃないんです
業を遺伝するんです 常に業に頼っているんです
生命の優劣は業が決めるのです
と経典が終了するのです
はい そういうことで えっと
まあ休憩取るならばどうします？疲れたならばここら辺で
では 疲れていなくても
じゃあ10分ぐらい 時間空きます
はい では後半始まります
で 自分の人生を自分でプログラミングするということで
これは他人に何もできることではありません
すべて性格の問題です
性格は自分で変えなくてはいけないんです
理性に監督を頼む 私たちの問題は
この感情が監督をやっていることなんです
だからいい作品にはならないんです
人生は 業であるプロデューサーは変えられません
なぜならば 業をどうすることもできないんです
業っていうのは 我々の行為によってエネルギーが溜まったっていうことなんです
ポテンシャルというんですから
私はね だから喋る 考える
行動する そういうのによってポテンシャルが溜まっていくんです
それはどうしようかということはできません
これはそのまま放っておいて
エネルギーをどうやって使うのかというところ
監督の問題なんです 私たちはどうなるっていう
この経典に取り上げているのは極端な例です
この１２種類に分けている人々っていうのは
このあとに極端でわかりやすい１２タイプなんです
え？あ １４ですね 例えば１３番目の無知な人っていうのは
まるっきり善悪を学ばない
バカにしている 頭ごなしに
他のことを勉強しているかもしれません
これだけが人生やと いうまあ極端なんですね
極端な性格を持ってる人々はそれほど一般社会では見られません
この１４タイプのに分けられるぐらいはどくちゃ難しいです
私たちの性格は善と悪が混じったものです
私たちのことを見ると
傲慢ま張ったり張らなかったりね
もう惨めになったりならなかったりはごちゃごちゃなんですね
たまたまあの善悪は何なのかとかね
勉強もしたり たまたままるっきり興味なく捨てたり
無視したり 時々人を助けてあげたりとか
時々まるっきり助けてあげないで
それに反対のことを言ったりとか
だいたい普通の人間っていうのは
そういう風にこのほとんど混じってるんですね
善悪は 善の力が多い人も
悪の力が多い人も その中でも善の方が力が多い人々はいます
それは皆様方はこの徳のある人とかね
恵まれている人っていうのは
善の力がちょびっと大きいんです
そこであの人は不幸ですねとかね
かわいそうですねという場合は
その人の場合は悪の力の方がちょびっと大きい
ちょびっとなんです そんなにすごいってことでもないんです
我々の人生は総合結果で構成されているんです
というということは 善もあるで悪もあるという人生なんですね
皆様の人生もそうでしょう
うまくいったり うまくいかなかったり
ちょっと失敗したり もうすごいひどい目に遭ったり
またすごくうまくいったりとかね
ゴロゴロ変わる人生なんですね
それはその他大勢の方々の人生そうなっているんです
特にこの現代社会はそうなっているんです
インドではもう激しい差があったんだからね
日本でもね 江戸時代とかはもう上下激しい世界で
その時はものすごい恵まれている人もいて
貧困どん底 不幸な人も極端な性格はいたんですね
しかし 社会が変わっていって
次に次に業が構成した我々の人生がなんかごちゃ混ぜということになっているんです
幸福かといえば うーんと
あんた不幸です うーんとっても言えないという状態でしょ
幸福とも言いづらいし
不幸とも言いづらいという状態です
極端に不幸な人も 極端な幸福な人もいません
現代社会では極端な幸福
極端な不幸というのはないんです
社会で皆様の社会で あの中東の世界じゃないんです
で それは言うんですね
中国でもすごい世界一大経済大国ですけどね
すっごい貧困の人々も結構いるんです
北朝鮮だったらね もう極端に幸福な馬鹿も
ものすごい一般人は極端に貧困でっていう
そういう時々そういう社会もありますけど
まあ一般論としては混ざっているんですね
善も悪も 性格は決まったものではない
そこでこの経典で皆さんに紹介してる
この性格の問題なんです
善悪の問題というよりも性格の問題
例えば殺生することは悪業
生命を慈しむことが善業
その一個の行為の話じゃないんです
殺生する性格 残酷な性格
他の生命の痛みは感じない
殺して喜んじゃうんです
その性格なんです この本当に怖いのは性格なんです
我々もちょびちょびと嘘をつくこともあるし
時々噂を言うこともあるし
悪行為です 悪行為ですよ
まあ酒も飲んじゃうし
それも悪行為なんですけど
そういう行為 一個一個の行為のことじゃないんです
性格のこと 例えばどなたかが私は絶対誰が何と言っても酒飲むのやめます
やめませんと 私はあの気持ちはありがたくてありがたくて
そうすると性格でしょ
その人はドカンと落ちるんです
まあ仕方がね あんた方はもうみんなで仲良く酒飲んでるんだ
じゃあ私も一杯飲みますという場合は
その時は悪行為するだけで
性格にそれほど問題はないんです
そこをよく理解してください
こういうポイントは普通のお坊さんたちからもちょっと教えてくれないところなんです
大体私が知っている範囲のお坊さんたちは
この行為に怒鳴っちゃうんですね
性格についてはほとんど気にしないんです
人が何か悪いことをしたら
えらい派手に批判する
これではちょっとおかしいと私は思います
だって どんな人間でも失敗するし
悪いことはしちゃうし
それで人を非難侮辱していいわけないでしょ
我々はどんな性格の人間かと
この総合的に見ないと
そこでこの性格そのものは決まったものじゃないと覚えてください
この西洋的にこの性格分析なんとか何だかすると
この人間には運命としてもうピチンと判子を押して
あなたはこの性格 風に決まってそんな決まってないんです
こういう風に勉強しましょう
過去は変えられません
もう過去は終わっちゃったんだから
今の人生の状態を素直に受け止める
受け止めた方がいいです
それはもうプロデューサーが今の人生プロデュースしちゃったんだから
私はもうちょっと 2センチ背が高かった方が良かったのにとかね
顔がもうちょびっと小さかった方が良かったのにとか
いい加減にしろと だから今の状況で受け止めること
それはこの災害に出会って不幸になっても
この状況を受け止めてほしいんですね
これはプロデューサーのせいなんです
災害の時はもうたくさんの人々が
同じ不幸になるんだけど
それでも個人の差があるんです
ああ もう全部財産流されて家族も亡くなった
ああ そういうことかと
それぞれ亡くなった方々の業で亡くなったと
生き延びている自分が自分の業でもう生き延びている
だから津波で家族が4人亡くなっちゃって
一人が残ったならば 4
人の寿命はそこで終わりなんです
この人は津波が来たのに生き延びたんです
だから業が短命ではなくて長寿の業を持ってるんです
だから死なないんです
だから そこはちゃんとそのまま受け止めて
ものすごく悲しい 寂しい
しても仕方がありませんと
起きたことは起きたと
だから我々はまず現在を受け止める
神に 仏に 親に 社会に 仲間に不平不満を投げても
さらに悪業することになります
それは悪業です 感情です
自分が不幸になってる
この世で神も仏もないんだとかね
言ってもあかん だからはっきり言えば
神に仏にいろんなあれこれ願いすることもあんまりよくないし
馬鹿にすることもよくない
そんなのは置いといて
親に文句言ってどうするんですかね
親が精一杯育てたんです
でも自分の監督がじゃなくて
プロデューサーが自分の業だから
自分が業を遺伝しているんです
親の遺伝子じゃないんです
親の遺伝子が遺伝子ならば親と同じくなるでしょ
でも親よりものすごい能力ある子供が生まれるわ
親は知識人ですけど 学校を中退してる子供が現れるわ
これって何だと 親が美男美女なのに
子供がそちらの反対ということもあるわ
時々すごい健康体ですけど
両親が 子供が障害を持って生まれるわ
そんな業がプロデューサーだからなんです
障害を持って生まれた子供は親に文句言ったっても
なんであなた私を産んだんですか？と
さらに悪業なんです さらに悪業なんです
だからそれも感情で自分の業を使っているんです
感情を使ってはならない
神も仏もいないんだけど
あなたの感情でしょ あんたいることもいないこともどちらとも知らないでしょうにと
自分の気持ち次第で神様ありがとうございますとか
仏様ありがとうございますとか
よう言うんですよ 理性で生きてみたらどうですかね
しかし 一切の現象は無常です
これはお釈迦様が説かれた真理です
性格も無常です 性格だけ変わらんというのはありえないんです
業も変えられるもので
運命 定め 決定ではありません
だから我々にアクセス不可能でしょう
業は アクセス不可能ですけど
変えられます 今も我々は業を変えているんです
だって業っていうのは資産家という感じで考えれば
もう悪いものをポテンシャルを持ってるし
良いポテンシャルも持ってるし
私たちはこのドラマをやりながら生きるというドラマをやりながら
そちらに悪いエネルギーと良いエネルギーを入れてるんで変わってるんです
業が だからお釈迦様は最初に善行為しなさいと一言で終わり
話は 善行為しないと言ったら
もうプロデューサーはすごい良いエネルギーでいっぱいいっぱいになるんです
結果出す時でもエネルギーの法則がありますから
正エネルギーは先にということ
いつでも正エネルギーは先を取るんです
だから性格的に残酷な人の場合は
その悪業が強烈ですよ
だから直行地獄に落ちるんです
業にとってはどうしようもないんです
自分が計算出すんです
資金出すんです 出した資金が悪なんです
だからそれなりの生命をプロデュースするんです
これからの人生を変えられます
ですから 我々は今日の人生を諦めて
これからの人生を変えるプログラムをするんです
悪業を善業に変える 変換することは不可能です
悪業を取り出して善業を生み込む
それはありえないんです
エネルギーはエネルギーです
善行為をたくさん行うことで
悪業の力は弱くなります
方法はそれだけです 例えば
10万円借金している人は金がないでしょ
借金したんだから 借金を 0 にすることはできないんです
その代わりに仕事をして
仕事をしていっぱい儲かっちゃえばいいでしょ
そうすると 10万円の借金って何のこともないんです
だからたくさん仕事をする羽目になったんです
借金した悪業で でもたくさん仕事をしたんだからね
それがなくなります なくなるんじゃなくて
借金払ってるんです なんのことなく消えるわけじゃないんです
日本の場合はね 誰かが借金して死んじゃったら
次の人が払わなくちゃいけないでしょ
で 薄める作業です 断言的に人は善行為をするべきです
これはまあどうしようもないんですよ
人殺したら 皆様にとっては社会に褒めてもらうってことはありえないんです
結果決まっているんです
誰にも関係ないよと言って自然破壊したら裁かれますよ
だから行為に結果も一応決まっているんです
決まっていると言葉を使いたくないんだけど
まあ因果法則ですよ だから窓ガラスに石を投げ
力一杯石を投げたら窓ガラスは割れる
これは当たり前のこと
だから行為に結果が  何て言いますか
もう因果法則で決まっているんです
だから我々は断言的に善行為をするべきです
何の理由もないんだよ
悪行為するためには ただ感情で下手な無知なバカな監督を雇っているせいなんです
感情で 悪を犯して言い訳するのではあります
頭がいかれてる監督が言ったことをやっちゃって
あとで言い訳するのよ
あなた 監督変えるべきでしたよと
感情の代わりに理性を監督にする
自分の会社にね 泥棒を雇ってもらって
不正ばっかりして金いろんな数字ごまかして金盗むプロがいて
その人を雇っちゃうと
それでその人は会社の金盗むでしょうに
誰のせい？だから自分に人を雇う権利があったんだから
それだったらいい人を雇うのは自分の責任でしょうに
だから私の人生に監督を雇う権利
私にあるんです だから私は理性と知恵を監督にする
それで素晴らしい人生っていうものを作ってくれるんです
この文章を書いたのは
みんな言い訳するんですね
悪いことをして もう徳のある人じゃないんだ
ある徳も消す人なんです
繰り返し善を行うことで
それが自分の性格になります
ポイントは繰り返すことなんです
性格を変える方法は繰り返し
ずっと朝 もう寝坊朝寝坊する人が頑張って早く起きる
次の日もいくら嫌でも早く起きる
1 週間になってくるともう変わっているのです
性格は 繰り返すことで性格は変わるのです
はい 次に性格を変えるプログラム
十善十悪があります これは今日は紹介しませんが
大乗仏教でもよく言うんですね
十善十悪 皆さんは覚えている方々もいるかもしれません
それは一個一個の項目なんですね
十善というのは殺生しないこと
パーナーパでもね アディナーダーナでもね
盗まないこと よくない行為をしないこと
嘘を言わないこと 暴言
侮辱の言葉 言われ 荒っぽい言葉を喋らないこと
噂を言わないこと 無駄話しないこと
それで ７つで それから異常な怒り
異常な欲と邪見 で 十は七つ
それは十善十悪と言っているんですね
しかし そういうのは一個一個の項目なんですね
これ性格にするんです
苦労してでも十善を行います
もともと性格が悪いです
みんな感情で生きているんだからね
だから十善を行うためには苦労しなくちゃいけないんです
もう一つあります 布施戒瞑想という３ステップもあります
それでプログラムできます
布施というのは人を助けることをいろいろあげることで
物惜しみをやめて できる範囲であげて
協力して社会といい関係を作る
それから道徳を守る 戒律を守る
それから瞑想してみるという３ステップでも人生をプログラミングできます
五戒を守るならば 過去の悪業の一部は実るチャンスが失います
で 五戒を守るだけででも結構幸福になります
自分のプロデューサーがね
いろんな悪業を持っているでしょ
はい 次に次にとかね 採算くれるんだから
悪党い採算が入ったら
こちら不幸ということになっちゃうんです
しかし こちらで五戒守っていると
理性が監督になっているんです
そうすると悪が舞っているんだけど
使う場がなくなっちゃうんです
このエネルギーでは このこのチャンスがなくなっちゃうと
もうどうすることもできないんです
例えば 私は人に石を投げる
それで人に当たって怪我するんです
しかし この人が理性があるんだから
感情じゃないんだから
何でお前ということじゃなくて
できることなら殴ってみる
傲慢があるんじゃなくてね
あ この人を怒って一生殴っているんだから
ちょっとどけよと で どけるんです
それでその人が理性があったんだから
あの その人が本当は怪我する業があったんです
そこを抜けちゃったんです
だから そうやってこの業に結果出すチャンスがなくなるということがあるんですね
慈しみを実践すると さらに過去の悪業がチャンスを失います
この慈悲の実践してみると
相当な悪業がチャンスがなくなるんです
ですから 慈悲を実践した方がいいんです
すぐ人生は好転し始めるんです
普段自分に怒る人は怒らなくなっちゃう
普段自分を馬鹿にする人は何のことなく馬鹿にする気持ちがなくなっちゃうね
向こうには そうやってこの業が悪業をね
コントロールすることはできます
ヴィパッサナー実践で悪業の力が弱くなり
悟りに達することで消えます
業そのものっていうのは
新しい生まれをプロデュースするエネルギーなんです
ヴィパッサナー実践 悟りに達したら
この業にある新しい生まれをプロデュースする力がなくなっちゃうんです
新しい生まれが作らなかったら
もうどうしようもない
業はもう無効 はい それで講演は終わります
最後 解脱に達す達しても
肉体は過去の業が作ったので
それなりの結果が受けなくてはならないんです
例えば人が悟ったとしましょう
悟ったらもう業のプロデュース能力が消えちゃったんです
しかし 今この肉体は前の悟る前の業が作った肉体なんです
その肉体ある限り いろいろ悪業善業が受けなくてはいけないんです
でも その悟った人は別に知ってるんだからね
受け止めるんです 寿命
幸福 死などは業の管轄で変えることはできません
で 今のこの肉体のね 寿命
幸福 まあその場合 幸福っていうのはどんなご飯食べるのか
どこに住むのかとか 何が好むのかとかあるでしょう
そういうのはなかなか
それから死ぬこと  プロデューサーの管轄です
例えば 解脱した素晴らしい智慧のある達人の阿羅漢たちが解脱してすぐ亡くなった涅槃に入ったケースもあります
悟ったそのまま亡くなると
悟ったんだから あと年ぐらいいた方がいいんじゃない？それはもう業にはその力がない
この肉体 は過去のものだからね
ゲッダッサは将来の善悪業の力を無にします
これ作った肉体は仕方がありませんからね
それからプロデューサーにはプロデューシング能力がなくなっちゃうんです
制作する能力がなくなるんです
だから あの あの因果法則の後でお釈迦様の喜びの疑るでしょ
この家を作る大工さん見つかったよと
あなたの資源を壊しちゃったよと
もう作れませんよと このプロデューサーのストーリーなんです
その芸にあるのは このアネーカジャーリサンサラ
結構覚えているでしょ
サンダービッサンガッビサンガハカーラカンガウェーサンと
この家を作る人を探していたんだと
お釈迦様は当時のこと
家を作る この肉体をね
プロデューサーを探していたんだと
なぜならば ドゥッカージャーティプナップナン
生まれる 生まれる 生まれる
生まれる きりがなく生まれる
これは苦しみであったと
ガハカーラカディットし
プロデューサーを発見しましたよと
プナゲーハンナカシ もう二度とあなた生命はプロデュースしませんよと
終わったよと もう なぜならば
サッパーデパーツがバッグ
あなたの資産をハチャメチャにしましたと
業を変えることができても
リミットも理解しましょう
だから皆様 毎日業を変えているんです
これは感情で生きているならば
悪業を入れて入れて このプロデューサーをすごい力強くするんです
それではなくて 善行を断然的にするべきです
善行為 善行為を断然的にして
プロデューサーはまた強くするのです
しかし 良いエネルギーで強くするのです
幸福をもたらすエネルギーで強くするのです
そうすると プロデューサーが天国か人間になったっても
寿命があって 美しい体で健康で長生きできる肉体を構成してくれる
だから天国に生まれたりする
しかし リミットもあります
リミットは何なのかと
黒人は白人になりません
例えば黒人でひどい目に遭っているとかね
すごい西洋の方が差別ありますからね
人種差別 それで自分が黒人で結構やられる
何かどこかでおかしいことで自分を先に疑う
で アメリカではこれ普通ですね
犯罪を起こしたらもう黒人で決まっていると
犯罪というのは白人だったら大目に見る
何の事もやっていない黒人を撃って殺すとかね
まあそれなりに法律であれやこれやとやってますけど
でもあとから警察官を訴えたっても意味がないでしょ
もう人が死んじゃったんだから
はい それである日 黒人が
これ皮膚の色でこんな苦労しているんだから
白人になってもう無理ですね
それだけは しかし その人にいっぱい善行をすることはできます
いっぱい善行為をして
社会に認められる 社会に愛される
社会が必要とする 信頼できる人間になることはできます
そうすると 皮膚の色はそれほど関係がないんですね
オバマさんが黒人だと誰も思わないでしょ
アメリカ大統領はそれだけで終わっているのです
そういうことで このまあこっちで書きたかったんだけど
例えば足が不自由で生まれる
これはどうしようもないです
しかし その人はいっぱい善行為をして素晴らしい人間になればいいんです
足の不自由は別に放っておけ
そんなのと目がなく生まれる
見えないことは放っておけ
放っておいて善行為しましょうと
そういう風に自分の人生を幸福な人生にプログラミングできます
そこでこのリミットも覚えていてほしい
このリミットは大したことない
わかりきったものなんです
だから 足が弱いんだったらね
車椅子でいいんです 目が見えないんだったら
点字もよく学んで 学校にも行って勉強もして
あれやこれやとか いくらでもできます
あー目が見えないんだから俺って不幸やと思った時点でアウト
文句言っちゃったんです
はい そういう風に このこれと話が終わりますけど
最後に書いたんだから
次また何も出せません
あっても で でも口で言います
人間っていうのは相当善業で生まれるんです
犬猫と違って 人間の今の業で天国の命もプロデュースできたはずなんです
だから私たちの問題は
私たちは感情で怒り 嫉妬
憎しみ 欲で生きてるんだから最悪
人生は だからそこは理解してほしい
誰だっていっぱい徳があるんです
ちょびちょびと障害持ってる人々を見ても
結構徳があるってわかるでしょ
だからそこをちゃんと花を生けるプロの先生のように
自分の人生を美しく徳をプログラミングすればよろしいのです
これは難しくない 善行をすると決める
それだけです はい そういうことで話を終了します
はい ありがとうございます
スマナサーラ先生 ありがとうございました
若干時間がございますので
もし質問のある方いらっしゃいましたら
挙手していただきましたら
マイクを はい  本日ありがとうございます
えっと 例えば中東なんかとはやっぱり厳しい世界ってことは
地域としてやっぱり業が悪業が多いところなのかっていうことと
日本はやっぱり不幸になっている人が増えているのかなと思うんですね
ということは 日本人はもっともっとやっぱり徳を積まなきゃいけないということでしょうか
はい そういうふうに思っちゃうと
すごい差別的な意識になりますから
そうですね そうですね
そうではないんです 誰だって無始なる輪廻転生をしているんです
だから誰にだってこの業の力っていうのはほぼ同じなんです
あの方々は我々より不幸というわけじゃなくて
この大量の業があって
どこら辺はログインになっているのかってことなんですね
例えば私はスリランカという国で生まれたでしょ
それで日本に住んでいるでしょ
そうすると私は日本の食べ物を食べたり
きれいな水を飲んだり
涼しい環境で楽々に生活しているでしょ
だから 環境によって私の無料の業のいいところが今ログインになっているんです
もし私がもう中東に行ったらどこでやられるかわからない
そこで環境によってもログインログアウトになるんです
それから自分の生き方によってもログイン
ログアウトになるんです
なんで慈しみを実践しなさいという場合は
いつでも善行為にログインするんです
アクセスするんです 慈しみの場合は
悪はそのままもう待ってるだけでチャンスがない
そういうことで あの 生命は犬猫であろうとも私たちと同じ業を持ってるんです
ただ犬になったんだから
ほんの一部しか機能しないんです
それだけです  ありがとうございます
あ 今日はありがとうございます
えっと 業によってその生まれ変わりが変わるっていうことはお話だったんですけども
えっと 今行った行為が今の人生にどのように返ってくるかっていう
あの メカニズムをもう少しお話ししていただけたらと思います
今行っている業っていうのは
一部がこの世で機能するんです
一部 残りはあの向こうの領域に入っちゃうんだよね
業の だから時々ありますね
自分がすごく素直で 何も悪いことをしない生活をするんだけど
それほど幸福になるっていうこともない場合もあります
私に至っても 個人的にね
何の悪いこともしないで生活しているんだけど
結構言われますね いろんな人に
日本の皆様に言われることは別に全然気にしないし
それは私が買っているものだから
悪口ばっかり言い張ったりしてね
で それは知識をちょっと刺激してあげたいだけでね
でも自分の中はね 何がしたいの？なんとかよとか
それはまあこうだと仕方がないということにしているんですね
はい どうぞと  そういうこともあるし
とにかくこの世で我々やることの一部は
自分には変わってくる
この世ではいいことをするとは自分が感情を抑えていることなんですね
だから 今の人生を自分がそれなりにプロデュースではなくて
監督の指令で変えているんですね
いい例を思い出しちゃったと
あのビートたけしさんがいるんですね
すごい能力のある方がね
あのなんかの場面で で
人殺し場面なんですね
それやったらビートたけしが違う違うって言うんですね
言ってそうじゃなくてって言って
本人がピストルで撃ってみせるんですね
まあ演技ですけど ものすごく残酷
こういう風にやらなくちゃいけないと
だからビートたけしさんがこの監督でも優秀な監督でもありますから
そのその場面がどう監督するべきかと
だから他の人やったことは生ぬるいと
人殺す場面だからみんなびっくりして大変だ
なんで残酷な人をと思ってもらわなかったら
いい演技じゃないんです
そういうことで 我々善行為すると
私たちはいい監督を雇っているんです
その分 まあいい方向になります
それだけです 別に説明するところではないと思いますけどね
この世でも結果があります
今 私の講演 全体的にもこの世でこの人生をプログラミングすることを言ったんです
まず この人生を幸福にプログラミングするっていうことも
この今行っている善行為なんです
それで終わらないという話なんです
業にいっぱい収入が入ってるんです
その方が大量です だから
我々はね 何か品物を一つ買っちゃうと
店にはほんのちょびっとしか利益入りません
入りませんね しかし その品物を作る会社が大量に金もらってるんです
いろんな現代電気世界時代だから
電子時代だからね いろんな
時々会社が特許だけ取って
みんなにそれを売るんです
新しい何か作って 特許を取って
品物を作りたい人々に
はいはい どうぞ これぐらい
これお金くれくれと 何もしないで金儲かってるだけなんです
そういうことで この大本が大量に儲かっちゃうんです
大本っていうのは業ですね
私たちにできるのは この人生で使える業が決まってる
運のマスから それも使えます
そういうことで まあどちらへ疑問になっているか
よく私には理解できませんでしたけど
この世でやることで この世で人生は幸せになります
だから時々我々はこういう風に
まあ過去は忘れてください
どうでも過去も将来もね
将来生まれ変わるかどうか
どうでもいいんですからね
今はいい人間になってくださいという単純な短絡的な言い方も使ってはいます
はい ありがとうございます
あ えーと 悟りについて質問させていただきたいと思います
えーと 預流果という悟りの段階に至った時に
有身見という煩悩はどのように変化を受けるんでしょうか
お願いいたします  有身見という錯覚だからなくなるんです
有身見が変化しません
初めからそれは錯覚です
今は錯覚であるとわからない
それだけ 例えば虹が光の屈折やと皆さんはわかってるでしょう
だから昔みたいに虹に乗って誰が誰かとそういう話は信じませんでしょ
だから初めからも虹っていうのは目の錯覚です
で終わり でも今も虹が現れます
だから有身見が錯覚だとわかっただけ...です
何も変化が起こるわけじゃないんです
はい  あの 追加でご質問したいんですけども
えーと 預流果における有身見が
あの まあ錯覚だということでなくなった後に
一来果における有身見というのも
またなんかあのなくなるっていうふうにはちょっと
一来果には有身見ないんです
一来果には自分がいるんだという
そういう気持ちしかないんですね
これは有身見じゃないんですね
変化している自分ということになっているんですね
一来果になってくると
なくなるのは欲と怒りなんですね
だから私には実体ありません
それでも生きているということでしょ
実体がないんだけど 変化しつつ生きている
で 生きているんだったら怒らなくちゃいけないし
欲を出さなくちゃいけないし
それでまた見据えて これまずいと
で 執着は減るんですね
この肉体に対して 肉体に対する心に対する執着が減ったら
その分怒りと欲が減っていくんです
不変化で消えてきれいさっぱり消えるという順番です
で すべて無我と 慢ですね
それ消えるのは阿羅漢果というところなんです
ありがとうございました
はい では終了しましょう
では 最後に回向の文をお唱えして終了したいと思います
合掌してください 回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サッビーティヨ ワンジャントゥ サッバローゴ ウィナッサトゥ マテー バワッタンタラーヨ スケー ディガーユコ バワ
バウドゥサッバ マンギラン ラッカントゥ サッバデーヴァタ サッバブンダヌバーヴェヌ サッバダンマヌバーヴェヌ サッバサンガーヌバーヴェヌ サドワ
サッティバワントゥティ
アビワダナシーリッサーニッチャンワンダパチャイノジャッタルーダンマワッダンティヤーユアンノウ
スカンバラン はい どうもありがとうございます
スマナサーラ先生 ありがとうございました